hey this is pressure Walker a test in
New Zealand recently made headlines for
leaving 15 year olds in tears because
they thought the problems were too hard
to solve one of the problems involved a
kite I actually recently made a video
presenting a solution which is probably
what the test makers intended the
solution to be but in the discussion of
that video the problem turned out to be
much more complicated and interesting
than I originally anticipated and there
actually was a flaw in my solution for
those who haven't seen the first video
I'm gonna first go over the problem then
present my solution and then show you
why there is a flaw in the solution and
how we can get to the correct answer so
let's get started by presenting the
problem the kite gdb e is placed in the
square a CHF DG is equal to G B is equal
to e G calculate the size X of angle D
be e justify your answer with clear
geometric reasoning can you figure it
out give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
the solution so here's how I solve the
problem which is probably what test
makers intended the flawed method I used
was to find a 30-60-90 triangle and
that's not the flawed part the flawed
part is how I found it so I got started
by drawing the diagonals of the kite de
and G B and letting them meet at Point I
since GDP E is a kite and DG equals e G
diagonal G B perpendicularly bisects
diagonal de I then said this means G B
equals de equals the length of the
square this would then mean the
following equivalences in particular DG
is equal to 2 times di and GE is equal
to 2 times ie
this means triangles d IG an e IG are
30-60-90 right triangles because the
right triangles which have a hypotenuse
which is two times one of their legs the
angle that's opposite the leg that's
shorter has thirty degrees therefore
angles DGI and EG i would be thirty
degrees from there i said let's look at
the isosceles triangles d g b and b GE
now since DG equals g b equals e g these
triangles are congruent isosceles
triangles by side-angle-side hence the
remaining angles that are not equal to
30 degrees will all be equal to each
other and this will bisect angle DBE so
each of these angles will be equal to
half of x furthermore we have the sum of
the angles and triangles is a hundred
and eighty degrees so we have two of
these remaining angles plus thirty
degrees is equal to 180 degrees these
angles are equal to each other and we
can then solve the two of these angles
is equal to 150 degrees and two of these
angles will equal x so 150 degrees is
the answer i got and that is the correct
answer but i'm telling you this is a
flawed method to find the answer why is
that where is the flaw in this proof so
here's the problem let's go back to the
diagonals of the kite i said looking at
this diagram we could conclude that g b
equals d e equals the length of the
square
it looks like g b is parallel to the
sides AF and CH so it looks like it's
exactly equal to the side of the square
furthermore the same thing for de it
spans the square and it looks like it's
perpendicular to the sides a F and C H
so you think these are the size of the
square and therefore they're equal to
each other but the diagram is
specifically not to scale so it's not a
justified
conclusion to say the G B equals D e
equals the length of the square in fact
this step turns out to be wrong the kite
could actually be rotated inside the
square so the diagonals are not parallel
or equal to the sides of the square I
think Christopher Knight
Steve's math e stuff and Joseph Lombardo
for pointing out this particular flaw in
the proof Christopher Knight even went
so far as to come up with a diagram to
show how the kite could be rotated so
imagine the kite is actually rotated in
the square like this he actually
presented values and showed that the
lengths of the diagonal will actually be
longer than the size of the square so it
is not in fact true that G B equals de
equals the length of the square
if the kite is actually off axis the
more remarkable part is that even if the
kite is rotated it still turns out that
X is equal to 150 degrees so since the
answer is still the same how can we fix
the proof to show that X is a hundred
and fifty degrees so what we need to
show is that G B equals de the diagonals
are equal to each other it doesn't
matter that the diagonals would have to
be the length of the square it just
matters that the diagonals are equal to
each other so how can we prove that
we'll draw DJ perpendicular to sides a F
and CH and will also draw B K that's
perpendicular to sides a C and F H now
we have two triangles that we will show
are congruent by angle side angle EJ D
is congruent to G K B by angle side
angle so why are these triangles
congruent to each other but one angle is
congruent angle EJ D is equal to angle G
be-because both are right angles by
construction next side DJ is equal to B
K because these are both equal to the
square side length we've constructed
these so that they're perpendicular to
two sides of the square so they'll be
parallel to the other side of the square
so we can say that D J equals B K equals
the length of the square what about the
final angle it's a little bit trickier
angle edj is equal to angle G BK the
reason is because since G B and de the
diagonals of the kite are perpendicular
they intersect perpendicular lines at
the same angle G B will intersect BK at
the same angle the de intersects DJ
because DJ is perpendicular to B K now
we can use the fact that the two
triangles are congruent to say that
their hypotenuse is G B and D e will be
equal to each other now that we know
that the diagonals of the kite are
congruent we can then say since we know
D G is equal to G B equals e G from the
given information and we've shown that
the diagonals are equal to each other we
can therefore conclude DG e is an
equilateral triangle this means angle D
ge is equal to 60 degrees next D G B and
E G B are congruent isosceles triangle
by side-side-side besides D G G B and E
G are all equal to each other and the
remaining sides are equal d b is equal
to b e because g DB e is a kite and g d
is equal to e G so the remaining two
sides will be equal to each other
therefore angle D G B is equal to angle
eg B which is equal to half of 60
degrees which is 30 degrees we can now
proceed as before where we have the
remaining angles are all equal to each
other and therefore they're all equal to
half of
and then we have the sum of the angles
in a triangle is 180 degrees so we can
then proceed to find that X is equal to
150 degrees just like before
so the key part in this proof is that we
have the diagonals are equal to each
other which then leads us to all these
steps they're not necessarily equal to
the site of the square there's also
another way you could have solved this
problem after figuring out the diagonals
are equal and then angle DGE is 60
degrees since G D is equal to G B equals
GE we can draw a circle centered at G
passing through points D B and E these
will be the radius of the circle I think
Ali a for pointing this out in the
comment now that we have a circle and
wave a central angle we don't actually
even need the square to solve for angle
X let's clean up our diagram a bit we
can now use the properties of central
angles inscribed angles and arcs of a
circle I'll put a point P on the major
arc of the circle so that I'll be able
to write the major and minor arc and
distinguish them the entire measure of a
circle is equal to 360 degrees so the
measure of Arc DBE plus the measure of
Arc dpe is equal to 360 degrees I've
written em to mean the measure of the
arc now the measure of Arc DBE is equal
to 60 degrees because the central angle
is 60 degrees so we substitute in that
value and that means the remaining arc
the measure of D PE is equal to 300
degrees so how can we figure out DBE
well the measure of angle DBE is equal
to 1/2 the measure of the arc by the
inscribed angle theorem
thus the measure of angle DBE is equal
to 300 degrees divided by 2 which is 150
degrees and that's equal to x
so we get to the same answer using the
property of circles and it's quite a
remarkable way I can't imagine the test
examiner's would have wanted this to be
what students would have presented as
the answer but it is one way you could
have come up with the answer that's
slightly out of bounds from the original
scope of the problem so did you figure
out the correct way to solve this
problem or were you like me and the many
people who overlooked the mistake I made
in the original proof thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math you can
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
if you like this video you can support
me on patreon and you can check on my
books which are listed in the video
description you can also catch me either
at mind your decisions or at pressure
Locker on social media depending on the
site